merci
nous allons donc proposer la suppression
de 5 régimes spéciaux les Français nous
regardent croyez-vous que nous allons
garder notre crédibilité et croyez moi
je fais pas dans la provocation que nous
supprimons un régime tout à fait spécial
très spécial qui est celui du Sénat qui
est un régime autonome mais pour les
Français spéciales autonomes tout ça
c'est la même chose comment allez-vous
garder une crédibilité pour dire vous
êtes des privilégiés vous êtes des
profiteurs vous n'avez pas de nos
critères de pénibilité d'ailleurs que
l'on ne réintègre pas les quatre et
notamment l'exposition au pesticides les
vibrations et que sais-je encore et bien
que nous notre travail est hyper pénible
parce que nous travaillons la nuit parce
que nous avons un travail vraiment
pénible et que il nous faut un régime
autonome et très spécial comment
voulez-vous que les Français nous
croient et de dire que en faisant jouer
sur un sentiment qui sont en fait ceux
des bases instincts l'envie la jalousie
sociale ce sont des profiteurs on
et je reprends ce que une maladie
comment voulez-vous faire quoi que les
clercs et autres salariés d'une notariat
qui dont le salaire est calculé comme
pour les fonctionnaires et sur dernier
mois qui sont excédentaires et qui sont
en pénurie comment allez-vous leur
proposer une telle pauvreté parce qu'ils
vont beaucoup perdre et tous les autres
vont beaucoup perdre on n'est pas un
crédit
[Musique]